- It's time for Moss or Ross.
- [Ross] Oh.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
- Okay, here's how it's gonna work.
We're gonna pick a random fact
and we're gonna pop it up on the screen.
And I have to decide who it pertains to.
I'd love for you to play along, everybody.
And since "Shining Girls"
is going to leave you
on the edge of your seat,
if I get the majority of them correct,
our audience is gonna go
home with this amazing prize
to help you relax.
'Cause, boy, do we all need
to relax in this world.
There's an intelligent
therapeutic massage device
from the company Lyric.
So I would like to, you know,
help you all relax.
- Yeah. Yes.
(audience applauds)
But Drew.
- Um, all right.
- Drew, only though,
I'm gonna say, but they only get it
if you're good at this game, right?
- Oh, God.
Well, let me try.
All right, number one.
Let's see the first fact.
Okay, fact one is "I once got third place
in a demolition derby."
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
- So we have to keep a
straight face, Elizabeth.
- Yes.
- Which is,
it's tough for me to
keep a straight anything,
so let me try.
- What do you guys think?
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Members] Ross.
- Ross.
I feel like it might be Ross,
because of how and where you grew up.
I'm gonna go with Ross.
(bell pings)
- Yes.
It is me.
(audience applauds)
- Nice.
- Yes it is.
You're gonna need like five
of those massage tools.
(Drew laughs and flusters)
- Okay, Let's see what's
next, I'm so excited, okay.
"I once appeared on the
screen with Hulk Hogan."
I'm going Moss for this one.
- [Audience Members] Yeah.
- Moss.
(bell pings)
(Drew squeals excitedly)
(audience applauds)
- Oh wait, we have a clip.
Let's take a look.
- Oh, we have a clip.
- Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Look at that.
- Bad kitty!
(cat meows)
(girl screams)
(audience laughs)
- Uh-oh.
- [Elizabeth] Look at that.
(girl screams)
- Thanks.
- Probably seven or eight.
- Get a goldfish.
(audience applauds)
- Wow!
- Thank you.
Thank you very much.
- That was the most...
That's a whole suitcase
to unpack, in itself.
- We all have to start somewhere, Drew.
- I love that!
- Yeah, some of us
start with Steven Spielberg,
but some of us (laughs)
(Drew laughs)
yet some of us start with Hulk.
- [Ross] Yeah. (giggles)
- I love Hulk Hogan.
(Ross and Elizabeth laugh)
All right, next, fact three.
"I've been alone to Disneyland
because I love it so much."
- [Audience Members] Ross.
- Oh, I love that
everybody is like, "Ross".
- [Audience Members] Ross.
- [Drew] Oh gosh.
- Look at that innocent blinking.
- You know what's so weird is
my instinct is that it's Moss, but...
Oh God, I'm going against the grain now.
- Hard.
(audience call out answers)
- All right, I'm going Moss.
I'm going Moss.
(bell pings)
(Drew squeals excitedly)
- Yes!
(audience applauds)
By yourself?
- (laughing) Yes.
Yes, I grew up in LA,
and sometimes there wasn't anything to do.
And I did, I drove to
Disneyland by myself.
- [Ross] Aww, did you
get a churro, at least?
- I had a great time, I
rode a couple of rides
and went home.
- Oh.
- It was great.
- I love it.
That's what it's there for.
"The happiest place on Earth".
- Yeah.
- We'll go with you next time, okay?
- Thank you.
I think I was excited I had a car
and I could drive somewhere and I wanted,
You know, I was like, "I
could drive anywhere I want.
I'm gonna go to Disneyland."
- Yes.
The world is your oyster.
"Handmaid's Tale", Season
five explores freedom,
you go to Disneyland.
- (laughs) Exactly!
We all have our idea of freedom.
- All right, number four.
"I know how to install
a lighting fixture."
(audience call out answers)
Oh, oh.
Oh, a little division here.
I see.
(audience call out answers)
I am gonna go Ross with this one.
(bell pings)
(Drew squeals)
- Yes.
(audience applauds)
I'm very handy.
- Very handy.
- I have a whole tool kit
and everything.
- Yes, you have.
- I did a YouTube tutorial
and learned how to do it.
- You're also like a walking pharmacy.
You're very handy.
Don't ever underestimate Ross.
- No, I'm like MacGayver, all right.
- Yes!
- I'll just solve any problem.
(audience applauds)
- MacGayver.
Yes.
- Done.
- That is genius.
- Have you ever said that before?
- No, maybe one time.
- Well, that might have to be a thing.
- Yeah, let's sell a whole sitcom.
"MacGayver", here to solve the crime.
All right, done. Sold.
- Um, all right.
- You should copyright that.
- We have one more.
"My biggest fear is deep water."
I'm going Moss.
(bell pings)
(Drew screams)
- [Ross] Yes.
(audience applauds)
That's it?
Your fear?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Oh, that's a scary one.
- All right.
I think I'm doing pretty good.
- Yes.
- Did I get any wrong?
- No, you did not, Barrymore.
- No.
You know you didn't.
(audience cheers)
- [Ross] And you know what that means?
- That means you're all going home
with these dope, really cool,
amazing Lyric massage devices.
I'm taking one and...
(audience applauds)
Oh, Rossy, I love you so much.
- I love you too.
- Oh, Mossy, I love you so much.
- I love you.
- Oh, God, I'm...
This is such a dream come true for me.
- For me too, are you kidding?
It really, really is.
- I have these giant pompoms
and they say, "Elizabeth Moss"
(Elizabeth chuckles)
and I'm always going like this.
- Thank you.
- Let it not be so long until
we see each other again.
- I know, we can't do that.
- Life, travel,
work, pandemic.
- Let's not.
- Please not.
- Yes.
- Okay, good.
You can catch Elizabeth
in the new series, "Shining Girls",
streaming now on Apple TV+.
(bright theme music)